[Music]
corporate governance is the system by
which business corporations are directed
and controlled it is the set of
responsibilities and practices used by
organizations management to provide
strategic direction thereby ensuring
goals are achievable risks are properly
addressed and organizational resources
are properly utilized the main aim of
corporate governance is to resolve the
conflicting objective of exploiting
available opportunities to increase
stakeholder value while keeping the
organization's operations within the
limits of regulatory requirements and
social obligations the key knowledge
statement is that a seesaw candidate
must understand IT governance management
security and control frameworks and
related standards guidelines and
practices top management will provide
assurance to stakeholders that IT
deployment is aligned with business
vision mission and objectives by
implementing an IT governance framework
a governance framework will comprise of
strategic alignment value delivery risk
management resource management and
performance measurement we will continue
to learn about IT governance security
management and control frameworks in
this grim implementation of an IT
governance framework will lead to an IT
governance framework that enables
stakeholders to be assured that IT
strategy is wholly aligned to the
business mitigation of risks in the
organization through critical controls
control determination by the risk
it addresses management utilizing
frameworks such as COBIT international
standards organization ISO among others
to set up good IT practices monitor and
improve them the is auditor using such
frameworks to benchmark the practices of
a particular organization let us focus
on the main areas of cover
in the following screen to cover this
knowledge area the sisa candidate should
have a good grasp of information
security governance is organizational
structure and responsibilities is roles
and responsibilities sourcing practices
policies reviewing contractual
commitments governance of enterprise IT
and performance optimization we would
look at some of the best practices for
government enterprise IT in the next
screen governance of enterprise IT
governance integrates and
institutionalizes good practices to
ensure that the enterprise's IT supports
the business objectives the factors that
have led to the rise in the importance
of governance of enterprise information
technology include business managers and
boards are now demanding a better return
on investment there is an increasing
concern over high expenditure on IT
management is increasingly under
pressure to meet regulatory requirements
for IT such as sox2 for banking
institutions among others the selection
of service providers is a key management
decision especially when such a decision
is being made with consideration to
service outsourcing and acquisition
increasingly complex IT related risks
such as network security
let us continue to learn about the best
practices for governance of enterprise
IT in this scram IT governance
initiatives that include adoption of
control frameworks and good practices to
help monitor and improve critical IT
activities to increase business value
and reduce business risk the need to
optimize cost by following where
possible standardized rather than
specially developed approaches the
growing maturity and consequent
acceptance of well-regarded frameworks
the need for enterprises to assess how
they are performing
against generally accepted standards and
their peers also called benchmarking in
the next screen we will learn about
information security governance
information security governance requires
strategic direction and impetus within
an enterprise it requires commitment
resources and assigning responsibility
for information security management as
well as means for the board to determine
whether its intent has been met the role
of board of directors Bo Dee's and/or
senior management in insuring
information security governance is
implemented include ensuring effective
information security governance is
achieved only by involvement of the
Board of Directors and/or senior
management in approving policy
appropriately monitoring and metrics as
well as reporting and trend analysis we
will continue to learn about information
security governance in the following
screen members of the board need to be
aware of the organization's information
assets and their criticality to ongoing
business operations this can be
accomplished by periodically providing
the board with the high level results of
comprehensive risk assessments and
business impact analysis BIA in the next
screen we will learn about the roles and
responsibilities of board of directors
in information security governance to
ensure proper information security
governance the board members should
approve the assessment of key assets to
be protected and that protection levels
and priorities are appropriate to a
standard of due care the tone at the top
must be conducive to effective security
governance it is unreasonable to expect
lower level personnel to abide by
security measures if they are not
exercised by senior management executive
management endorsement of intrinsic
security requirements provides the basis
for ensuring that security expectations
are met at all levels of the enterprise
penalties for non-compliance must be
find communicated and enforced from the
board level down let us look at an
example of importance of information
security in the following screen
importance of information security
information security is about setting
the right culture towards protection of
information assets in an organization it
is difficult to convince employees to
observe particular controls such as need
to periodically change their passwords
even on the personal email and the CEO
insists on not changing his or her
password
note that the requirement to change
password after completing a given period
is enforceable by the is management from
the server side or back end we will
learn about the roles and
responsibilities of the senior
management in information security
management in the next screen the roles
and responsibilities of senior
management are as follows the executive
management in an organization has the
key responsibilities of implementing
effective security management governance
and defining the strategic security
objectives of an organization this focus
and support must be carried in a
continuous basis the steering committee
has the responsibility of focusing on
all security aspects of an organization
the security committee should be
representative of the respective groups
or functions that are impacted by
information security this allows
achieving of consensus and trade-offs on
matters of information security such as
priorities plans risks controls etc
while allowing better communication the
chief information security officer ISO
ensures that good information security
practices are carried out within the
organization such as ensuring employees
take care of their passwords let us
learn about governance of enterprise IT
and various management frameworks in the
next screen following are some of the
frameworks
standards for the governance and
management of enterprise IT COBIT v
iso/iec 27001 ISO 27001 ITIL IT baseline
protection catalogs or IT grande shoots
catalogs information security management
model is m3 iso/iec 38,500 2008
corporate governance of information
technology iso/iec 20000 we will learn
about each and detail in the forthcoming
screens let us begin with COBIT 5
iso/iec 27001 and ITIL in the next
screen COBIT 5 is the latest edition of
the COBIT series by Asaka COBIT stands
for control objectives for information
and related technology COBIT is a good
practice framework that supports IT
governance and management in ensuring
that IT is aligned with business so as
to maximize the benefits COBIT 5 is
generic and useful for enterprises of
all sizes whether commercial
not-for-profit or the public sector
iso/iec 27001 also known as iso 27001
provides guidance on implementing and
maintaining information security
programs this standard was initially
published as british standard 7,000 799
or b s 7,000 799 ITIL is a hands-on
framework that provides a means of
achieving operational service management
of of IT developed by the UK office of
government commerce OGC with IT service
management forum we will learn about IT
baseline protection catalogs and is m3
will continue to learn about governance
of enterprise IT and various management
frameworks in the next screen IT
baseline protection
catalogs or IT grande shorts catalogs is
the collection of documents over 3,000
pages useful for detecting and combating
security weak points in the IT
environment this framework is a
collection by the German Federal Office
for security in information technology
FSI information security management
model is m3 is a process based is M
maturity model for information security
let us proceed to discuss iso/iec 38,500
2008 and iso/iec 20000 in the following
scram iso/iec 38,500 2008 is a corporate
governance of information technology
framework for effective governance of IT
it assists those at the highest
organizational level to understand and
fulfill their legal regulatory and
ethical obligations with respect to
their organizations use of IT this
framework provides guiding principles
for effective efficient and acceptable
use of IT within their organizations
iso/iec 20000 is a specification for IT
Service Management that is aligned with
ITIL S service management framework you
will now attempt a question to test what
you have learned so far in this topic we
will learn about the concepts under the
knowledge statement or KS 2.2 let us
begin with is strategy standards
procedures and policies in the following
screen the key knowledge area is to
understand the purpose of IT strategy
policies standards and procedures for an
organization and the essential elements
of each the key elements in this
knowledge are to ensure IT governance is
effective through a formal framework
that consists of IT strategies policies
standards and procedures should be
consistent with business requirements it
is also important to ensure effective
management and mana
avicii as well as ensure management has
implemented effectives controls over the
decisions direction and performance of
IT to have a proper understanding of
this knowledge area the sisa candidate
should ensure that they have a good
grasp of governance of enterprise IT
best practices for governance of
enterprise IT and information system
strategy we will learn about information
system strategy in the next screen an
information system strategy articulates
the enterprise's long-term intention to
use information system to improve its
business processes based on the business
requirements when formulating the is
strategy an enterprise must consider the
following business objectives and the
competitive environment current and
future technologies and the costs risks
and benefits they can bring to the
business the capability of the IT
organization and technology to deliver
current and future levels of service to
the business and the extent of change
and investment this might imply for the
whole enterprise cost of current IT and
whether this provides sufficient value
to the business and the lessons learned
from past failures and successes let us
look at some best practices for
governance of enterprise IT in the next
screen governance of enterprise IT GE IT
implies a system in which all
stakeholders including the board
internal customers and departments such
as finance provide input into the
decision-making process GE IT has become
significant due to a number of factors
such as business managers and boards
demanding a better return from
investments concerns over generally
increasing level of IT expenditure the
need to meet regulatory requirements for
IT controls in areas such as privacy and
financial reporting the selection of
service providers and the management of
service outsourcing and acquisitions IT
governance initiatives that include
adoption of control for
works and good practices to help monitor
and improve critical IT activities to
increase business value and reduce
business risk we will continue to look
at some best practices for governance of
enterprise IT in the following screen
the need to optimize costs my following
where possible standardized rather than
specially developed approaches the
growing maturity and consequent
acceptance of well-regarded frameworks
the need for enterprises to assess how
they are performing against generally
accepted standards and their peers
governance process should focus on
monitoring evaluation and direction of
the conformance and performance the
system of internal controls and
compliance with external requirements we
will look at IT governance focus areas
in the next screen the focus areas of IT
governance are strategic alignment value
delivery and risk management strategic
alignment focuses on ensuring the
linkage of business and IT plans by
defining maintaining and validating the
IT value proposition and aligning IT
operations with enterprise operations
value delivery is about executing the
value proposition throughout the
delivery cycle ensuring that IT delivers
the promised benefits against the
strategy concentrating on optimizing
costs improving the intrinsic value of
IT risk management involves requirement
of risk awareness by senior corporate
officers a clear understanding of the
enterprise's appetite for risk
understanding of compliance requirements
transparency about the significant risk
to the enterprise and embedding of risk
management responsibilities into the
organization you will now attempt a
question to test what you have learned
so far in this topic we will learn about
the concepts under the knowledge
statement or KS 2.3 we will begin by
looking at
channel structure and roles and
responsibilities related to IT in the
following screen the key knowledge area
for a seasick candidate is to understand
organizational structure roles and
responsibilities related to IT
organizations must clearly define
organizational structures which define
responsibilities of major functions
within an enterprise and how these
structures ensure proper segregation of
duties let us look at the main areas of
coverage in the next screen the key
coverage areas for this knowledge area
include IT governing committees
information security governance
organizational change management is
roles and responsibilities and is
organizational structures and
responsibilities note that the sisa exam
will not be testing specific job
responsibilities as they may vary from
one organization to another
however the sisa candidate may be tested
on the roles and responsibilities of
business owners information security and
executive management functions as they
are universal function in addition the
sisa exam may test separation of duties
which is also referred as segregation of
duties let us look at information
security roles and responsibilities in
this grand organizational structure
charts provide a clear definition of the
department's hierarchy and authorities
on the other hand job descriptions
provide is Department employees a clear
direction regarding their roles and
responsibilities the system development
manager is responsible for programmers
and analysts who implement new systems
and maintain existing systems in an
enterprise a project manager is
responsible for planning and executing
is projects and may report to a project
management office or to the development
organization additionally he or she may
have to carry out a number of duties
that include utilising budgets assigned
for the delivery of is initiatives
report
on project progress to the is steering
committee executing the vision of the IT
strategy and IT steering committee by
planning coordinating and delivering is
projects to the enterprise we will learn
about is roles and responsibilities in
the next few screens job descriptions
provide is Department employees a clear
direction regarding their roles and
responsibilities a service desk also
known as a help desk is a unit within an
organization that responds to technical
questions and problems faced by users
such questions and answers can be
delivered by telephone fax email or
instant messaging at times service desk
personnel may use third party help desk
software that enables them to quickly
find answers to common questions there
should be a procedure to record the
problems reported solved and escalate it
should be in place for analysis of the
problems or questions such a procedure
will help in monitoring the user groups
and improving the software information
processing facility IPF services there
are various service desk activities
which include acquiring software SW and
Hardware HW training end-users to use
hardware and software informing the
users of hardware or software problems
initiating changes to improve efficiency
determining the source of system
problems an end user is typically
responsible for operations related to
business application services the term
end user can be used to distinguish the
person for whom the product system was
designed from the person who programs
services or installs applications such
as financial management information
system FM is customer relationship
management CRM enterprise resource
management ERP to distinguish between a
user and an end user it is in
important to note that the term user is
broader and could refer to
administrative accounts and accounts to
access platforms such as an application
account that accesses the database on
behalf of an application while an
end-user is a physical person that
accesses systems and end-user support
manager is usually responsible as a
liaison between the is Department and
the end users Data Manager is
responsible for the data architecture in
larger IT environments as well as being
tasked with managing data as a corporate
asset an information security management
is a function that generally needs to be
separate from the is Department and
headed by a corporate information
security officer see ISO the CIS L may
report to the CIO or have a dotted line
interact reporting relationship to the
CIO it is worth to note that even when
the security officer reports to the CIO
there is a possibility of conflict since
the goals of the CIO are to efficiently
provide continuous IT services whereas
the CIS ou may be less interested in
cost reduction if this impacts the
quality of protection
Quality Assurance manager is responsible
for negotiating and facilitating quality
activities in all areas of information
technology vendor and outsourcer
management there has been a general
increase in outsourcing including the
use of multiple vendors such as those
for software development equipment
maintenance printing services online
payment services infrastructure services
ISP etc a number of dedicated staff may
be required to manage the vendors and
outsourcers including performing the
following functions acting as the prime
contact for the vendor and outsourcer
within the is function providing
direction to the outsourcer on issues
and escalate internally within the
organization and
function monitoring and reporting on the
service levels to management review
changes to the contract due to new
requirements and obtain is approvals
infrastructure operations and management
an Operations Manager is responsible for
computer operations personnel including
all the staff required to run the
computer information processing facility
IPF efficiently and effectively such
activities include computer operators
librarians schedulers and data control
personnel the information processing
facility IPF includes the computer
peripherals magnetic media and the data
stored on the media IPF constitutes a
major asset investment and impacts the
inter-process ability to function
effectively the computer room should be
secured and only authorized personnel
should have access no one except
operations personnel should have access
to the IPF media management is required
to record issue receive and safeguard
all program and data files that are
maintained on removable media data entry
is critical to the information
processing activity data entry can
include batch entry or online entry the
systems administrator is responsible for
maintaining major multi-user computer
systems including local area networks
Wireless local area networks wide area
networks personal area networks storage
area networks
intranets and extra nets and mid-range
and mainframe systems security
administration begins with management's
commitment management must understand
and evaluate security risks and develop
and enforce a written policy that
clearly states the standards and
procedures to be followed the duties of
the security administrator should be
defined in the policy to provide
adequate segregation of duties this
individual should be a full
employee who may report directly to the
infrastructure director Quality
Assurance personnel usually performed
two distinct tasks quality control and
quality assurance quality control QC is
responsible for conducting tests or
reviews to verify and ensure the
software is free from defects and meets
user expectations this could be done at
various stages of the development of an
application system but it must be done
before the programs are moved into
production
Quality Assurance QA in itself helps the
is Department to ensure that personnel
are following prescribed quality
processes for example QA will help to
ensure that programs and documentation
adhere to the standards and naming
conventions systems analysts they are
the specialists who design systems based
on the needs of the user and are usually
involved during the initial phase of the
system development life cycle SDLC
security architects they evaluate
security technologies design security
aspects of the network topology access
control identity management and other
security systems and establish security
policies and security requirements one
may argue that systems analysts perform
the same role as that of the architect
applications development and maintenance
application staff are responsible for
developing and maintaining applications
infrastructure development and
maintenance staff are responsible for
maintaining the system software
including the operating system network
administrators are responsible for key
components of this infrastructure
routers switches firewalls Network
segmentation performance management
remote access etc so far we have learned
about various roles and responsibilities
of information security let us proceed
to the next screen and discuss the
segregation of duties or s OD matrix
this table illustrates an example of
segregation of duties matrix the rows
illustrate various is duties while the
same aren't replicated at each column
where there is an x mark it means the
duties are incompatible to each other
and therefore one individual should not
perform this role for example an
individual with the role of a control
group CG should not be a system analyst
si a system analyst should also not
perform the role of a quality assurance
person it is recommended to take a look
at this matrix as it is important for a
sisa candidate you will attempt to
question to test your knowledge in the
next screen in this topic we will learn
about the concepts under the knowledge
statement or KS 2.4 in the following
screen we will look at the development
and maintenance of IT strategy
procedures standards and policies the
key knowledge area here is to have a
grasp of the processes for the
development implementation and
maintenance of IT strategy policies
standards and procedures the key
concepts here are to ensure that IT
strategies must be defined on business
objectives and that IT strategy should
continue to address both emerging and
developing business risks the main areas
of coverage include strategic planning
information security governance and
information security management we will
learn about strategic planning in the
next screen information system strategic
planning relates to the long term path
an enterprise wants to take in
leveraging information technology for
improving its business processes
strategic planning should ensure that
the plans are aligned and consistent
with organization goals and objectives
and that the enterprise's requirements
for IT systems and the IT organizations
capacity to deliver new functionality
through well governed projects are
considered the sisa
candidate should understand and pay full
attention to the importance of IT
strategic planning
management control practices into
consideration let us look at information
security governance in the next screen
information security governance is
focused on confidentiality availability
and integrity of information continuity
of services and protection of
information assets the key outcomes of
effective security governance should
include strategic alignment risk
management compliance and value delivery
the outcomes are enabled through the
development of three things one is
performance measurement which measures
and monitors information security and
report on it to ensure that smart
specific measurable achievable relevant
and time-bound objectives are achieved
two is resource management which ensures
information security infrastructure and
knowledge effectively and efficiently
utilized and finally is process
integration which ensure organizations
management assurance processes are
integrated within security so as to
improve overall security and operational
efficiencies the next screen will focus
on information security governance
framework the information security
governance framework will generally
consist of a comprehensive security
strategy intrinsically with business
objectives and governing security
policies that address each aspect of
strategy controls and regulation other
factors are a complete set of standards
for each policy to ensure that
procedures and guidelines comply with
policy and effective security
organizational structure void of
conflicts of interests and
institutionalized monitoring processes
to ensure compliance and provide
feedback on effectiveness we will look
at information security management in
the next screen information security
management provides the lead role to
ensure that organizations information
and information processing resources
under its control are properly protected
information security management is
achieved through performance measurement
which entails developing business impact
analysis disaster recovery plan
and business continuity plans the major
component in establishing such a
connection involves application of risk
management principles to assess risks to
IT assets mitigate these risks to an
acceptable level hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here